il est arrivé comme une véritable rock
star sur le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tiger woods le
golfeur américain en 14 grands chelems a
été l'attraction de cette 42e ryder cup
auprès du grand public et pour moi c'est
incroyable de voir e tiger woods
du coup une chuis père content sinon
plus une résurrection d'un joueur qui
était tombé très très très très bas et
qui a été remonté qui remontait avec
beaucoup de volonté
fort de sa victoire le dimanche
précédent sur le circuit américain à
atlanta tiger woods espérait briller
sportivement dans une compétition qui
n'a remporté qu'une seule fois en huit
participations
nous avons bien voyagé avec l'équipe
hier soir c'était sympa mais simplement
de passer la soirée avec mes coéquipiers
avec tout le staff
aujourd'hui bon c'était bien de celui
des tendances se dégourdir les jambes
golf tiger woods a finalement été
l'ombre de lui même le tigre est reparti
avec trois défaites en double et une
défaite en simple sur ces quatre matches
disputés sur les greens saint quentinois
ryder cup c'est pas son truc au niveau
jeu jusqu'à maintenant alors maintenant
elle a encore deux ans pour s'est
qualifié pour la prochain je pense qu'il
va repartir d'ici
avec la queue entre les jambes est
vraiment avec un mal de tête demain
matin après cette ryder cup 2018 tiger
woods affiche désormais un bilan de 13
victoires 21 défaites et trois nuls en
37 matches sous le maillot américain
l'un des pires bilans de l'histoire dans
cette compétition
[Applaudissements]